yet another new strain of the
coronavirus in the uk
this one with origins in south africa
and the health secretary announced
immediate action to stop it spreading
we've detected two cases of another new
variant of coronavirus here in the uk
both
are cases both are contacts of cases who
have traveled from south africa over the
past
few weeks first we are quarantining
cases
and close contacts of cases found here
in the uk second we're placing immediate
restrictions
on travel from south africa and finally
and most importantly
anyone in the uk who has been in south
africa
in the past fortnight and anyone who is
a close contact
of someone who's been in south africa in
the last
fortnight must quarantine
immediately the variant called 501 v2
has caused a surge of infections in
parts of south africa
it has a higher transmission rate and
may be more prevalent in the young
significantly the mutations could enable
the virus to elude
antibodies from a previous infection
that has the potential to mean
that people can get reinfected
potentially and that's something that
we're actively
studying at the moment to see how many
of the
recent infections and and the cases that
are coming through
are possibly re-infections and what
about the vaccine
we're trying to very rapidly understand
what the implications
are for for the vaccines scientists are
still getting to grips with the uk
variant
there's still no evidence that it causes
more serious disease but it has spread
nationwide with a higher proportion
found in children that could make
control more difficult if schools are
allowed to reopen in january
mostly during the lockdown period in
november
you see a statistically significant
significant
increased proportion of cases in under
15 year olds
for the bearing compared with the
nonparents you know children are
are now more like adults in their
infectiousness than they were with the
previous strains that
that will pose greater risks of of
uh in transmission involving children
mixing with each other
and you can i mean potentially there are
challenges there for
particular types of control measures and
what we want to do with schools
the chance emergence of two new variants
that evolved thousands of miles apart
underlines the importance of rolling out
the vaccine worldwide
the pandemic isn't over until it's over
everywhere
or the virus could come back to haunt us
thomas more sky news